Il y a des trucs où franchement, c'est, il faut avoir de l'imagination, quoi.
Et il y a des trucs de rapidité, où la vraiment ça va être le buzzer.
Et il y a un petit trophée à la fin, que tu peux ramener chez toi si tu gagnes bien évidemment.
(Intro QUIZ YOUTUBE 2)
Bonjour et bienvenue sur le QUIZ numéro 2.
On est de retour pour tester la connaissance en culture de YouTube,
des candidats qui sont autour de la table.
À ma gauche, EnjoyPhoenix.
Salut Marie !
Salut !
(applaudissements)
Incroyable !
Nous avons Laink juste à côté.
(applaudissements)
Bonjour.
Vous serez euh, la team Trasheur.
Ouah !
Ça c'est cadeau.
Direct, comme ça.
À ma droite, nous avons la team Espadon.
(rires)
Avec euh, Germain de Dr Nozman.
(applaudissements)
Et Terracid.
Qui forment le duo iconique Cyprien Gaming avec son ami, son ami Laink.
On va commencer avec la première manche, ça va être des QCM.
Il faudra trouver la bonne réponse.
(musique)
On va commencer avec les Espadons.
Quelle chaîne YouTube n'existe pas ?
"Simplement Déborah".
"Juste Zoé".
"Vraiment que Sophie".
(rires)
"Uniquement Leila".
(hmm-mm)
Moi, tu vois, comme ça, de visu, Vraiment que Sophie ça me choque un peu dans le sens où,
(rires)
ça veut dire qu'il y a une chaîne qui s'appelle déjà genre "Seulement Sophie" tu vois.
"Uniquement Leila" m'intrigue.
(rires)
Non vraiment c'est...
Autant être honnête.
(rires)
"Uniquement Leila"...
Sur ce coup-là j'crois que je vais te laisser le jouer mais je pense qu'"Uniquement Leila" c'est...
Ouais alors je préfère te suivre alors.
D'accord comme ça c'est moi qu'est responsable.
J'vais dire "Uniquement Leila".
Ce n'est pas du tout de point, c'était "Vraiment que Sophie".
(ohhh)
Oh c'est tellement dommage.
Bah alors la poiscaille.
(rires)
J'me demande si mon raisonnement était correct.
Il était très bien, c'est juste que t'es en train de douter de ton coéquipier finalement.
Yo les Trasheurs.
(rires)
Super.
Laquelle de ces vidéos n'est pas une vidéo de Maouno ?
"Il met du caca sur sa copine".
Ça c'est faux.
"Il met du caca dans la bouche de sa copine".
"Il fait caca sur des gens".
"Il met du caca dans ses yeux".
Mon Dieu.
Il en a fait trois ?
(rires)
Y'en a trois qu'existent.
Maouno du coup, qui est un YouTubeur qui réagit à des vidéos.
Mon cerveau est vide.
(rires)
Comme les gens qui cliquent sur ses vidéos j'imagine parce que là ça...
Ouuh.
Tu partirais sur quoi ?
Bah Trasheur, Trasheur.
(rires)
T'as une petite idée ou absolument pas ?
Bah alors moi tu vois je dirais, le caca dans la bouche de la copine c'est quand même un...
Fin c'est dans la bouche quoi.
Tout ce qui est très putaclic, c'est ce qu'il a sûrement fait.
Ouais c'est ça, donc ça c'est 400 000 vues le caca dans la bouche.
(rire)
Ouais, c'est un petit ratio, ouais.
Minimum, minimum.
Moi j'dirais il fait caca sur des gens parce que c'est quand même compliqué.
(rires)
Juste techniquement.
On peut faire des putaclics, mais à un moment techniquement...
Il faut le faire.
Franchement j'y crois pas, moi j'dirais plutôt il met du caca dans la bouche de sa copine.
Celui-là je suis pas sûre, je pose mon veto.
Sur quoi tu cliquerais ?
Franchement mais...
Ouais en fait c'est surtout ça, sur quoi tu cliquerais ?
Si on vit dans un monde bien, ce serait dans la bouche de sa copine.
(rires)
J'suis prêt à te suivre.
Non, j'suis prêt à te suivre.
On va mettre ça.
Alors en fait ça existe, désolé.
Et c'est "Il met du caca dans ses yeux" qui n'existe pas.
(rires)
On va pas visionner la vidéo.
C'est vrai que c'est quand même plus hardcore !
On va me croire sur parole.
Dans les yeux on s'en fout.
(rires)
On est nuls là pour l'instant...
Ouais, ouais très très nuls là !
Nan, c'est eux qui sont nuls. T'as vu les questions ?!
T'en penses quoi toi qui es grand gagnant ? C'est nul là pour l'instant ?
C'est dur ! Vos questions elles sont dures !
(rires)
Team Espadon ? La poiscaille on est parti.
Quel titre de vidéo de TheKairi78 n'existe pas ?
Oh la chance !
(rires)
"Méfié vous des gens".
Ahhh...
"Dégustation complaitement folle".
"Regarder ce que sont mari fais".
"J'en n'est marre."
Alors là, c'est compliqué...
(rires)
Moi honnêtement, j'ai jamais trop regardé cette personne.
Moi si, assidûment !
*rires*
Et les quatre pourraient exister.
Et il ne ment pas, il regarde tout le temps !
Je te conseillerai de ne plus m'écouter.
Parce que je donne les mauvaises réponses,
donc allez, je vais dire une réponse, tu vas dire l'inverse.
D'accord ok on fait ça.
Il sort beaucoup de vidéos quand même.
Il fait des dégustations.
6 vidéos pour jour donc...
Ah ouais.
Moi je dirais dégustation.
Vas-y, j'te suis.
Je vais partir aussi sur "Dégustation complaitement folle".
C'est le premier point pour la poiscaille !
*haa*
*applaudissement*
Bien joué !
Faut le faire !
Faut des choses là
Ok pas de problèmes
Yo les trasheurs !
Salut !
Oui...
Je m'habitue toujours pas hein...
Bah oui...
Quel tuto drague n'existe pas sur YouTube ?
Dra... -C'est ta spécialité ça ?
Oui... oui j'adore !
"Draguer une caissière".
"Séduire une fille qui dort".
"Séduire une fille qui n'est pas intéressée".
"Séduire une fille qui court".
Ah. -Ouuf...
Moi, je dirais "Séduire une fille qui dort".
Ça sent le piège, le petit piège Cyprien ça...
Moi j'irais vers celle-là aussi.
Moi "Draguer une caissière" je pense que c'est totalement un tuto tout à fait faisable...  -Ouais, ouais.
Euuuh "Séduire une fille qui court" pareil.
Oui c'est rigolo, ouais
"Une fille qui n'est pas intéressée" je pense que c'est typiquement le genre de choses que tu tapes quand...
quand tu n'as pas de copine...
Donc je dirais "Séduire une fille qui dort" mais la dernière fois je t'ai proposé quelque chose ça n'a pas marché...
J'sais pas parce qu'une fille qui dort tu vois c’est pas possible !
Et c'est pour ça qu'on va cliquer !
"C'est pas possible !"
C'est..."Elle dort quand même !"
Non mais "Olala c'est incroyable !"
Il me faut une réponse maintenant.
Roh allez "Une fille qui dort" bon bah voilà !
Et c'est aussi le premier point pour les Trasheur !
Bien joué, bien joué, bien joué, bien joué !
(applaudissements)
Moi, j'aime bien séduire une fille qui court !
Parce ce que ça évoque vraiment
la fuite, mais, vas-y, essaye qu'en même !
(rire)
C'est une belle égalité, je trouve... Pour cette première manche
Il va falloir maintenant partir sur un
petit peu de rapidité faut se mettre un petit peu
dans le contexte faut imaginer l'éducation nationale
va pas bien. Plus personne ne s'intéresse à son cours d'histoire
et ils ont décidé de s'inspirer de ce qui se fait sur
YouTube. Donc je vous donne un titre putaclic
et il faut imaginer l'évènement historique
qui en découle.
(musique)
Rapidité, hein ?
WTF c'était pas l'Inde ?!
(buzzer)
Christophe Colomb !
Oui !
(rires et applaudissements)
Comment il fait ça ?
Mais oui, bien joué !
J'ai vu la vidéo, en fait...
(rires)
Le mec qui fait comme ça, tu sais !
Storytime : ma mère est vierge.
(buzzer)
Bah, euh... La Vierge ?
Euh..., la naissance de Jésus ?
Oui !
Bah voilà !
(applaudissements)
On tente le record du plus gros Ice Bucket Challenge... Ça tourne mal.
(buzzer)
*rire et applaudissement*
Dernier point attention sur cette manche
Pire traversée en mer de ma vie et quel accueil en arrivant
*buzzer*
Moïse !
Non
Merde !
Il n'y avait pas de bateau !
On relance,on relance
*rire*
Attends,attends
*buzzer*
Le vent des globes
Non pas du tout
il y a qui qui avait un bateau dans l'histoire
Y'en a plein je crois...
Y'a pas...Est ce qu'il y a quelqu'un dans la salle peut-être ?
Quelqu'un qui s'y connait en bateau et en histoire ?
Le débarquement ! Et c'est un bon point...
Ah putain ! Évidemment ! Ils avaient pris un bateau !
...pour JD.
Bravo. (applaudissement)
C'est une petite manche d'histoire, comme ça, histoire de se mettre en bouche.
Attention !
On va revenir sur une manche qui a cartonné la dernière fois.
C'est "Lequel youtubeur ?"
Il faut deviné de quel youtubeur je parle.
Ça parle essentiellement de youtubeur francophone.
Quel youtubeur a dit, à propos de moi, "ces podcast sont honnêtement nul mais de là à avoir 4 millions de vues...mouais" ?
(rire)
Oh le salop !
Est ce que lui même fait des podcats ?
(bruit du buzzer)
Squeezie !
Oui !
(rire et applaudissement)
Alors j'ai entendu...
...j'ai entendu un petit...
Ça va le traitre ?
...un petit ricanement
Attention, c'est repartit !
Quel youtubeur a sortit un spectacle en DVD ?
(buzz)
Norman
Oui, bien évidemment !
Quel youtubeur a fait une vidéo en Irak ?
(buzz )
Le Grand JD
Oui !
Il y a beaucoup beaucoup de point de ce coter là.
Il est chaud...!
Cyprien : "Attention"
Ils sont trop chaud sur le buzzer là.
Quel youtubeur va sortir un album ?
(buzz)
Mister V ?
Mais non mais c'est dégueulasse ! Regarde !
(rire)
Incroyable
Quel youtubeur a été champion de babyfoot ?
(buzz)
Est ce que c'est Wartek ?
Oui !
(rire)
Casse-toi !
Vas t'en à un autre quiz...
Elle les a toutes.
Et un dernier, attention.
Quel youtubeur a arrêté, puis est revenu, puis a arrêté, puis est revenu, puis a arrêté...?
Tsukiyo Power
Non !
Pas mal.
Quel youtubeur a fait une vidéo "le vrai retour" par exemple ?
(rire)
Et là, pour le coup, il...
(buzz)
DiabloX9
Ouiii
(applaudissement)
Bien joué, bien joué !
Qui est un peu notre parrain à tous.
Non mais c'est vrai. Il fait partie des premiers gros youtubeur.
Les Trasheur, il faut se réveiller un petit peu.
Ouais mais...
La Poiscaille là...
C'est un problème de main.
C'est un problème de main parce que les réponses je les ai.
Nous allons arrivé sur la manche putaclic.
Je vais vous montrer des miniatures et il va falloir deviner le titre.
Cette fois-ci, c'est 3 points qui vont être gagné.
On va commencer avec les perdants sil' vous plait.
Non...
Voyez cette miniature.
Quel est le bon titre ?
"Rentrer dans le mauvais trou ?!"
"Je renverse ma cup"
"En fait ce n'était pas un verre à shot"
"Grrr j'ai mes règles"
Je partirai sur le 'je renverse ma cup"
Tu vois, les petites gouttes de sang comme ça, ça me fait que...
Les gens aiment les règles.
(rire)
Du sang sur la miniature, des règles dans le titre...
Tu la connais ou pas ?
Non, je ne la connais pas.
Merde.
Je renverse ma cup, c'est soft.
Ouais mais vu que la miniature est quand même bien trash.
Ouais c'est vrai, c'est vrai, Je te fais confiance."
"Je renverse ma cup". C'est mon dernier mot Jean-Pierre.
Et c'était..."Rentrer dans le mauvais trou".
(rire)
Nan ?
Nous ne sommes pas là pour juger.
Avec la cup et tout...
C'est vrai ? Sérieusement ?
Regarder bien cette miniature.
"Prank, je lui fais croire que je couche avec sa copine, ça tourne mal"
"Prank, la maitresse crois que j'ai mangé des craies"
"Prank, j'appelle le proviseur à 22h"
Mais non...
"Prank, je fais croire au CPE que j'ai fugué"
Oh je l'ai vu.
Moi je l'ai vu.
(rire)
Moi aussi, mais moi aussi je l'ai vu...
Je l'ai vu aussi
Je l'ai vu dans les tendances.
Ça mérite d'y être donc euh...
Donc c'est la première.
Nan mais nan...
Si si...
Bah ça se voit qu'il a couché avec une fille
(rire)
C'est 3 points.
Et mais ils ont de la chance parce que...
Ouais franchement...
Même moi je l'ai vu.
C'était bien "je lui fais croire que je couche avec sa copine, ça tourne mal"
Si on fait, je pense, 2 fois 3 points, c'est peut-être suffisant.
En fait, je mens.
Tu peux le dire si on a perdu...
Vous avez perdu !
Oui voilà.
Alors...
Allez, pour le fun !
Découvrez cette miniature.
Nous avons comme titre :
"Mon chauffeur Uber est magnifique"
"Mon chauffeur Uber m'a kidnappée"
"Mon chauffeur Uber m'a giflée"
"Mon chaffeur Uber m'a reconnue"
C'est la deuxième : "Mon chauffeur m'a kidnappée"
Ouh...
T'es sûr de toi ?
Oui
Elle s'appelle Tana Mongeau et je crois que c'est ça .
Mais je...j'espère que c'est ça.
Elle va carrément nous filer le Timecode, c'est le temps limite.
Et c'est 3 points pour nos amis les Trasheur.
(applaudissement)
Si on s'en réfère du coup au titre, effectivement, elle s'est fait kidnappé par un chauffeur Uber.
Il y a une frustration. J'ai envie d'aller voir toutes ses vidéos.
Genre "qu'est ce qui se passe vraiment ?"
On est en train de donner des centaines de millier de vues comme ça.
On s'est pas rendu compte.
Dernière miniature. A vous de deviner.
Il vole ma mini moto, je le frappe.
La chaine Youtube de MOMO
Dégustation candy sale tourne mal avec MOMO